coming off the injured list he missed
one start with some tightness in his
right forearm the right-hander john gray
yeah 29 year old former first round
draft pick out of the university of
oklahoma he's making his 25th start this
season and third
versus the giants this year he's now in
his seventh season with the rockies he's
seven and ten with the four point one
three 126 innings pitch almost a strike
on an inning gray fires la stella hits
it to the left of second trevor stories
got it down over to first for an opening
out for john gray here's the o2 from
john they want to fastball up that's a
perfect location up
in the top outer third
of the strike zone
and a strikeout of gray goes to a
secondary pitch
and fans crawford with wade at second
and tony making his 27th start of the
year
[Music]
11-6 a 3.24 era
had a good year coming off a really
really good outing against the dodgers
very encouraging and that one a
comebacker discovany who
says he experiences a little more
discomfort with that ankle on plays like
that
now he pitches and a slider strikes him
out swinging beauty
now gives him the sign he wants 3-2 is
swung on and missed strike three how
about that 3-2 slider
a couple of strikeouts and a scoreless
first
strike three
second time john
has caught a giant looking that's his
third strikeout
and down goes yostremski so john feeling
it
02. they executed that slider and
cassalli is the fifth strikeout victim
of john gray
fastball down the right field side long
way to go for yastremski into foul
ground makes the catch
and then softly collides with that wall
and that netting maybe the best range of
any right fielder in the game right now
yastremski showed it off seems like an
opportune time for bud black to maybe
throw hit and run or get hampson moving
[Music]
and it's instead of a hit and run it's a
straight steal attempt and he's out
cassalli throws out garrett hampson two
down
hams doesn't get a great jump because
sally just makes a good throw and a
better tag by brandon crawford and you
see that a lot the throw that has upped
the first base side of the bag runners
at first and third
two down two hits and a walk in this
third inning that caught stealing a big
play oh two and blackman on a two-strike
count hits one right where tommy la
stella is standing
he takes off and duggar hits the ball
the year to
left field pretty deep but playable for
tapia he makes the catch
and that's all for the giants in the
fourth through the powerful trevor story
that is a foul
belt over and bell whoa what a play and
hopefully he's okay
wow that was a heck of a play
that could damage a rib cage the way he
went into that that railing yeah a lot
can go wrong injury-wise in this
situation you can flip over the rail and
end up in the camera well you can jam
your leg into the net or into the pole
there
you can take a little hit little hip
check with the with the railing
you look at him right there i mean we're
obviously the knee issues that he's been
facing this year
not a hundred percent
strike three to sally's gone
96 mile an hour fastball that's the
seventh strikeout today
john 02 pitch
strike three called got him with the
fastball
john gray with back to back strikeouts
here in the fifth
both of them called third strikes eight
punch outs on the day the 1-0 is a
ground ball to second brendan rodgers on
over to cj crone it's a one two three
frame for john gray
halfway through no score elias diaz who
fouled out to the right fielder
yastremski will swing at the first pitch
and loop it down the left field line
fairball
hit right on the chalk
elias
loops in
a leadoff double down the left field
line the rockies
get a lead off man in scoring position
now john gray
trying to help himself
that'll work through the left side john
gray says i'll take care of it
one-nothing colorado
a great opportunity to open up a
significant lead base is loaded for
charlie blackmon
and this is bounce to second you got to
get up the line charlie
beats the throw and the rockies get a
second run
that wasn't quite hit hard enough double
clutches and still makes a good strong
throw
that's all it took for charlie to be
safe
first and third for story
and this ball driven a fairly deep left
field and it is off the glove of wade
one run is scored blackman to third
story to second
three to nothing colorado
trevor quite screws this one up it's a
little bit off the end of the back
wait gives chase it's a nice play for
wade
go down as a double
slams right into the wall
actually went off the heel of his blood
on no outs
brandon crawford's the tying run
three-nothing rockies
crawford
left field way back there still going
goodbye
and this game is tied brandon crawford
goes the other way
to tie the game his 20th home run of the
year
well right guy right situation right
ballpark
you get some base runners one swing in
the back can change the game brandon
crawford did just that and the rockies
have diaz up there again he started that
three-run rally last inning with a
double
oh boy high fly deep left at
gun
elias diaz puts the rockies back in
front with his 16th of the year what a
great story for diaz gets a hanging
curveball up knows it off the bat 95
miles an hour violent swing
[Applause]
this is a rocky's team that was lacking
so much in offensive production
from the catcher's position now to get
16 home runs from diaz
crawford from second yestremski from
first
here's the stretch there they go the
pitch
the swing and the ground ball right to
short story over to first
the inning is over
shotseen works out of it
and we're going to see the major league
debut of colton welker he's going to
pinch hit
and this ball lifted to deep center
field duggar going back still going back
and he'll make the catch
about 420 feet from home play three men
on still nobody out the bases are loaded
now and here is lamont way junior one
two
wade line drive base head right center
field lavon wade's done it again
dubon and estrada they both score giants
have gone ahead
five to four how many big hits this year
for lamont wade junior late in games and
it'll be the first at bat of the
afternoon for evan longoria who had to
come in the ball game mike gustremski
couldn't continue five four giants ninth
inning
that one is smashed to center field
going back on the ball hampson and he's
not gonna get it it lands longoria base
hit belden wade both score it's seven to
four giants
charlie blackman trying to keep the game
going he won't do it
pop-up shallow left coming in duggar he
wants it he's got it and the giants come
from behind in the ninth inning the
former rocky jake mcgee slams the door
shut in the bottom of the ninth and the
giants have a terrific win and a
three-game sweep
in denver the first team as well as the
rockies have played at home all year the
first team to sweep the rockies at coors
in 2021